Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
CUE,
a language for
validating data amongst a whole bunch of other
things that we're gonna dive into in today's
session.
Now before we do that, this is a
little bit of housekeeping.
First, if you're not already subscribed to the
YouTube channel, you know, please feel free to
do that now. Click the bell and you'll
get notifications for all future episodes.
We stream weekly and loads of various cloud
native and Kubernetes content. So hopefully, we're for
you.
If you're not watching live, I would encourage
you to join our Discord server. There is
lots of good conversation and chat around cloud
native and Kubernetes in that channel, and we
also talk and suggest
new tools and technologies to cover on this
show.
And lastly, I wanna thank Equinix Medal. They
are my employer, but they very kindly allow
me the time and resources to invest in
this show producing cloud native learning materials for
us all to learn together.
If you wanna try Equinix Metal, then you
can use the code, the raw code. This
will get you $200 of credit.
You can spend that very quickly on fifty
hours of compute on a beefy instance or
get up to four hundred hours of compute
on something a little bit more modest. Check
it out. Let me know how you get
on.
Now today to dive into CUE, I am
joined by its creator and maintainer,
Marcel Van de Hausen from the Google team.
Hey there. How are you? Thank you for
having me. Good. I'm doing good. Thank you
for having me.
It's always great to be able to, you
know, demonstrate what I've been working on. So
appreciate that.
Yeah. I'm really excited. I'm a a big
fan and almost advocate of CUE. I feel
like I'm always telling people to go check
it out, and I'm really looking forward to
this, just kind of having a bit of
fun today and showing people how cool of
a a technology that is.
Cool. Before we get started, why don't you
just take a few minutes to introduce yourself,
and then we'll we'll start and tell people
what CUE is.
Yep. So I'm Marcel van Lowhausen. I'm
employed at Google. Been working there for a
long time.
Was on the founding team of Bork and
started out in the search engine team. And
then
after a few years, ended up on the
GO team. Went
hung out there for a while.
And then a couple years ago, I started
working on CUE and, you know, to sort
of realize
some of the vision that we had earlier,
really, in the early Borg eras, but but
never got to, if you will.
So and that's how I ended up here,
I guess. Nice. Awesome.
So I believe you're gonna do
a little bit of a a presentation just
to introduce us to CUE. I would encourage
if you wanna just get your screen ready
for that, we can move into that. I
would encourage everyone watching to, you know, get
your questions and send them over to us.
We'd happy to answer them as we go.
And there will be a hands on section
afterwards as well. Yep.
You get to play Fender Window. Right?
Yeah. I think I've I'm there already. Yeah.
Yes. There we go. Perfect. Thank you. Yeah.
So I hope alright. Great. Yeah. So I'll
get right to it.
So, first of all, what is CUE used
for?
So it's really an offspring of GCL.
So JSONET itself is is an offspring of
GCL. But,
rather than focusing on just data configuration,
it really tries to cover the entire configuration
space. Right? So things that has been used
for is is, like, fact discovery, workflow definition,
configuration,
data templating,
even cogeneration,
policy checking,
test generation even,
and Istio uses it for open API generation,
for example.
So a little bit of the history behind
it.
So, as I mentioned already, I started on
the you know, I was on part of
the initial Borg team.
And one of the reasons I ended up
there is, because I worked in this little
project before Borg,
which was sort of like Borg, a little
project,
little system that I created was like like
Borg.
And
so already, that system had a lot of
knowledge in it from how do you deal
with configuration. So some of it was, experience
from before that that Google had on, like,
how do you you know, what should you
not do, especially.
But also from my previous employer,
you know, we worked there with configurations. There
were hundred thousands of lines.
Managed and distributed teams,
you know, purely declarative and was fine. Right?
So that was a good example of of
how,
you could do declarative configuration and how powerful
it is. Right? And this was basically the,
idea we wanted to put into
into,
Bork as well. So this is what, GCL,
was originally.
However, we made some errors with GCL,
which made it, sort of not possible to
realize that original,
goal anymore.
Right?
So this is one of the things that's
that prompted CUE, right, to to do to
do it again right, right, to really get
these promises from from,
declarative configuration management.
So, also, a lot of things changed
in in this time. Right? So the Kubernetes
team, which is sort of an offspring from
of Bork,
they did their own research in configuration,
and they
drew their own conclusions.
Somewhat
different,
but, you know, very valuable lessons to be
learned.
And I tried to also incorporate that in
in the in the design of CUE.
Right?
And then, of course, also my Go experience,
you know, how do you deal with with
programming languages and languages in general, had a
big influence on how it end up looking
now. Definitely looks very different now than if
I'd written it fifteen years ago.
So some of the key takeaways from all
this knowledge that went into it, I think
the by far, the biggest one is, like,
never ever use overrides. Right? Just just don't
do it.
To qualify a little bit better, like, you
can have one level of overrides.
This was already the conclusion we had before
this this very early system.
But more than one layer, it just gets
too complicated. Right? And it doesn't matter if
you have file overlays or inheritance. Just don't
do it.
The other thing is you really wanna separate
code from configuration.
So this is another thing that went sour
in GCL.
So there you see that that there is
actually a lot of com computation
in in GCL in the end.
So the problem is here that we thought,
you know, you could always separate it by
pushing the computation into the binaries, but then
that's kind of a, you know, too idealistic
view. And in practice, that doesn't really work.
So you have to deal with this reality
that on the one hand, you do wanna
have com computation at the configuration layer, but
you still really wanna separate the two.
Something that came in later, more from from
Brian Grant and
folks from the Kubernetes land is the the
whole idea that parameterization
is is,
even though abstractions can be good,
generally, parameterization
and configuration is bad.
So CUE has a so I agree with
that, but CUE takes a different approach in
solving that problem.
So one other
thing to mention here is that if you
look at configuration, how it develops within a
a company
is that,
well, first of all, the best thing is
to have no configuration whatsoever. Right? Like, in
the ideal scenario,
you know, you have maybe one parameter to
tweak, and that's it. Right? Like, you you
you you don't tweak anything.
So in practice, what happens is that, you
know, systems develop, you know, more and more
things that you can configure.
So at some point, people start pulling it
out of the system,
you know, then then and into individual configuration
value. So that gets hard to manage, so
people start to develop systems around it.
Ultimately,
that's it's still too inflexible, so people end
up with DSLs.
And then these DSLs end up being so
complicated that people think, like, well, if it's
it's so complicated anyway, why don't we put
it in code?
And you get back to the top. Right?
And the whole cycle repeats itself again.
So
if you look at what's,
you know, this is a a a phrase
taken from cloudgoogle.com
describing,
the whole notion of,
you know, like like,
configuration as data,
or infrastructure as data, rather, is that, you
do want to be able to, record everything
in a single version control. So it's kind
of nice if your configuration is text. Doing
it declaratively
has a lot of benefits,
especially because it makes the contracts between all
the boundaries of your system very clear.
So if you think about this clock and,
like, considering all these options, like like, having
something text based
and declarative is is still the best option
if you can do it well.
Right?
So the problem is, how do we avoid
this,
complexity? Right? And this is one of the
main aims of CUE to make this, simple,
right, and and do not get into the
same trap as many other configuration languages where
there's too much computation, too much,
complexity in general.
So,
so let us take a big step back.
Right? Like, what is configuration?
So you have templates, data, validation rules, policy.
Right? And and, really, if you think about
it, all of this is spread,
across many different components. Right? So you can
have a person or or team that provides
a system.
Right, the system itself is configured, but then
also,
users of that system can provide additional configuration,
right, which then has to be combined in
a certain way.
Then also, this can come from multiple customers.
That system itself might use another system, all
of which have config configuration that's somehow related
to each other.
Right? And if you try to combine this,
it ends up being not that simple. Right?
So, really, it looks a little bit like
this. Okay. So you have some some data
that needs to be filled out in templates,
and then you have validation rules, but these
validation rules only work on concrete data.
So you have to make sure that all
the templates are filled out in the right
order, and this can be across systems.
And it just gets this really big mess.
Right? Very
complicated.
So
and this happens at all different levels. Right?
So combining data. So what happens if you
conflicting,
values? Right? Like, how do you override it?
Like, what's the order?
Same thing with rules and data or, like,
what comes first? What data do we need
to evaluate first before we can even apply
the rules?
What if you can't get the data at
all? Right? Like, how do you deal with
with incomplete data?
You have different sources, JSON schema, open API,
like, all this stuff. Right? And
then to make matters worse,
so configuration tends to be a cross cutting
thing,
right, where you really don't have a specific
order in which things get combined. Right? It
really comes in from every different angle, and
there's very little,
control you have over this. And in order
to manage that, then people tend to, like,
dumb down their systems or or sort of
restrict the configuration in a way that that
reduces the functionality of the system.
So
how does CUE address this? Right? So the
idea with CUE is that, okay. Well, let's
get a grip on configuration
and,
you know, create some way of dealing with
configuration that you actually can throw it all
together on one big heap. So, you know,
you don't have to worry about the order
of application anymore. You just dump it in
all one big bag, and CUE figures out,
how to combine it and how to do
all the validation and and data production.
So how does CUE do this? So there's
a few things that change. So to the
user,
now everything has to be done declaratively.
Right? Like, a big part of CUE is
that it unifies
rules and data, and, like, all of this
is the same thing. Right? So to CUE,
all these different aspects of of configuration are
unified into a single space,
if you will. So I'll let that sink
in for a moment. Right? And and I'll
I'll come back later to what does that
exactly mean.
But this is basically,
what CUE does.
And to the user, what it means is
that CUE puts some restrictions
on what you can do with overrides. Right?
So you have basically default values, which you
can see as an override. So that's one
level. But after that, you're done. Right? Like,
once you set something to a specific value,
you can never override it. So Dareit limits
you, right, like, more, more than other systems.
On the other hand, it gives you a
lot more flexibility and composition. Right? So where
you wanna
combine things from different angles, you now can,
whereas whereas previously, you had to specify a
certain order.
So this is to the user how things
change.
So for what the CUE, the way it
handles this is basically defining a very
rigorous
model on what configuration is and then having
a logic reasoning engine underneath it,
you know, to to deal with it. And
it sounds very complex. Right? But a good
analogy about this and it is. It is
actually very complex.
But the idea is that this complexity is
a complexity for the implementer, for the purse
the people that write CUE,
but it serves to make the life of
the users easier. Right? It's very much like
a garbage collector. Garbage collector is very complex
to implement or can be if you do
it right.
But the whole purpose of it is to
make memory management much easier for the user.
Right? So this is a little bit how
you should think of this.
Next slides. There we go.
So another way to think of CUE is,
so if you have a spreadsheet, right, like
you have all these cells where you can
put in formulas and you can refer to
other cells,
so CUE is really like a,
a spreadsheet for JSON. Right? Rather than having
a matrix, you have your JSON tree,
and you take base basically individual notes
and express these in terms of other notes.
Right? And then there's this logical reasoning engine
that that helps you execute that. Right? So
that's really another way, to see what it
is.
So
CUE is not just a language. It's a
whole ecosystem.
So there's the CUE command. There's all kinds
of, higher level libraries that allows you to
specify
workflows.
There there's all kinds of adapters to translate
back and forth to different, formats,
API generators,
policy engines you can build on top of
this. Right? So there's all kinds of tools
for injection and how you combine different piece
of data, different levels.
There's refactoring tools, formatting. So CUE is very
much designed for automated generation also. So the
the language is, designed for machine generation and
readability.
So that's how CUE looks like. And when
when
you think of it as a language, right,
like coming back to the DSL side of
things, when you think of it as a
language
so
what requirements do you have as a configuration
language? Right? So people,
might be aware of the difference between a
scripting and a programming language. So a programming
language,
is much more focused on readability, can be
a little bit more tedious to to, to
write. Right? But really, the point is that
it's correct
and that people can read and understand what
it what it does. Right? Because,
a programming language is maintained by multiple people.
Right? Like, sometimes it has to be,
read again over a long period of time.
Even the original author might have forget exactly
what it does.
So the same thing holds even more for
configuration languages,
because now it's not only,
you know, often it's written by the original
team
that maintains a piece of software, but very
often, it is then maintained or changed by
somebody outside of that team.
Right? And the type of people that that
work on that might not be the peep
you know, might not be the same kind
of group that is familiar with the original
language
that that product was was written in. Right?
So so think of an SRE team. Right?
You cannot expect them to be,
you know, very familiar with every language that
all of the systems they maintain is written
in. Right? So you need to to have
something that's even more familiar, more readable, and
and simpler to understand.
And this is complicated. Right? So this is
a little bit what they
what they try to do with Go. Right?
And the whole idea is that simplicity is
complicated, and it is.
But, ultimately, it makes life of everybody easier.
So what does CUE look like? So I
mentioned already before that CUE,
unifies types and values and constraints, policy validation.
It's all the same thing.
So if you look at the bottom, you
basically have,
in this this Moscow,
entry, you basically have JSON with syntactic sugar.
Right? Like, if you squint your eyes a
little bit, it's just JSON. You have key
value pairs.
So if you look at the top, it
looks more like a ghost structs. Right? Like,
you have a a the name of the
structs, you have the fields, and then the
types.
Right?
So in the middle, you see something that
is smack in the middle of these two.
So you have a large capital. So the
name is, again, a string. A capital is
now set to true, fixed to true, and
population is set to be greater than 5,000,000.
Right? So here you see this whole spreadsheet,
analogy coming back as well. And, really, you
can mix and match,
concrete values with types, with constraints,
however much you want within CUE.
Then CUE is also aspect oriented.
So what that means so one way to
view CUE as well so remember that I
said it's just, sort of a spreadsheet for
JSON.
So if you generalize JSON or if you
wanna see what JSON really is, right, like,
it's you can see it as a tree
of of data.
But another way to view it is a
path,
with some concrete value at the end of
that path, right, and then a sequence of
that. So you have it's basically a sequence
of path value pairs.
Right?
And, basically, what you can do in CUE
is the value doesn't have to be a
concrete value. It can be any type.
But, also, the path doesn't have to be
a single path. It can be
any group of paths. Right? So, for example,
if you look at the this last name
example here,
so we can say last name is Jones,
so you have the path and a concrete
value.
I can say the last name
is a string, which means it's of a
certain type. I can also say it's of
a type,
you know, of a certain subset of strings,
namely this any string that starts with a
capital letter,
which doesn't even work for my last name,
but, you know, it's just an example.
But what you can also say is that
every field that ends with name,
right, I wanted to start with a capital
letter. So here you see a group of
paths,
combined into a,
you know, assigned a single type.
So now I'll so first of all,
let me ask if there's any
questions or if this was clear. I'll stop
sharing.
Yeah. It was definitely very clear. I mean,
you also gave me, you know, the fear
that I've been doing configuration wrong my entire
life. But, you know,
I think there's a lot of, you know,
wisdom in in those slides and and, you
know, really, your articulated the problem that we
have very well and how you hopefully CUE
is gonna come in here and and kinda
help us do this all better. So that
was really great.
Actually, even while you were talking, I was
tweeting, I loved that line that inheritance is
questionable in programming, but it's fatal in configuration.
Like, I just think that was Yeah. That
was perfect.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, in Go,
you see they're already starting moving away from
this. I I mean, it has inheritance, just
no subtype inheritance. Right? But,
another way to see it with inheritance is
so one of their critiques of CUE is
that people say,
you know, well, this is too complicated for
for software engineers because they're used to inheritance.
Just use inheritance. Right? So so maybe that's
true.
But for anybody that's not a software engineer,
inheritance itself is kinda crazy. Right? Because, basically,
what you're saying is,
okay. Let's say we have a cat.
Right? And now we wanna create a dog.
So, okay. Let's inherit from cats because they're
kinda similar. They both have four legs and
stuff.
So we just override a cat and say
the the nose is now wet instead of
dry and it barks instead of meows. And
now we have a dog. Right? So to
any normal human, that would be absolutely insane.
Right? And and and it kinda is. Right?
So the way,
so the way you solve it in CUE
is to say, like, okay. You cannot have
a dog inherit from cats. You create an
animal.
Right? You can still have a hierarchy. Right?
But you create a a mammal. Right? And
then you have a a cat and dog,
instance of that. Right? You make it always
more specific. Everything you do is making everything
more specific.
And that's that's really the basis of it.
Yeah.
Awesome.
I think one of your friends and maintainers
has joined us. Paul Jolley says, CUE sounds
like fun. Hey, Paul.
Yeah.
And
yeah. So let's I know we have no
questions right now. So why don't we dive
into the demo? Again, if you're watching and
you have questions that you want us to
answer, please drop them into the chat, and
we will get right on to that. I
will pop your screen up with the
code.
Yep. There you go. Take it away. Yep.
So yeah. So I just wanted to give
a little feel here for what it means
you can just dump things together, right, with
CUE.
So
so here I have a little directory with
nope. Wrong directory. Good thing I checked.
So here I have a little directory with
a bunch of files.
And
so let's look at a n dot JSON
and b dot YAML.
So here you see two files. They both
define a restaurant's,
you know, top level restaurant map with, you
know, name,
you know, like like, basically, a name of
a restaurant and then some structs
describing the restaurants. Right?
So if I do
queue exports,
a dot JSON pretty much get what I
saw there.
Right? Then I can,
combine it with,
with the YAML one and basically,
well, let's do the output in YAML, a
little bit shorter.
Demo effects.
Alright.
It's my Go heritage. Still not used to
this.
So, basically, what you see is it combined
these fine into a single,
single map. Right? Because there's basically no overlap,
and everything is fine. So so this provides
you a way of combining,
you know, like JSON, YAML, whatever whatever you
want.
So
now the next question is, if I look
at,
for example,
I have another file here.
So what if I combine these two files?
So what would happen?
Alright. So let me do that.
A dot json, e dot json.
So basically, happens is complaints
complaints because,
it's the same restaurant with the same key,
and but they both define this cuisine field,
right, with a different value. And CUE basically
says you cannot do that. Right? Like, that's
the the cat and the dog
issue again. So so, basically, it says resolve
this. Right? Like, I cannot resolve this.
So
another thing you can do so let me
open
so the schema here.
So another thing you can do is apply
schema. So here I have a JSON
schema in written in YAML.
So what I like to do with JSON
schema because I find it kinda hard to
read, I can basically,
turn it into a CUE schema. So CUE
reads JSON schema natively. It uses this this
schema definition and some other,
clues to to figure that out.
And this is essentially how the queue looks
like. So I have a top level restaurant
map,
and then which is, you know, of type
restaurant.
There's a cuisine and a list of tables,
which basically describes,
you know, like, how many seats and whether
it has a view or not.
So very, very simple schema.
So
now I can,
basically, I can use the schema to verify
if,
my my values were correct. Right? So I
can do it with a dot schema. It's
a correct restaurant.
B dot schema was correct.
But now I have here, I have
so let me open a verb first.
So I have a code.
Was it this one? I think so.
So here I have another YAML
thingy.
So I can do a vet, so I
don't wanna see the output. I just wanna
validate if it's correct.
So I can run it, and now I
get a, you know, error,
which is correct because if I look here,
right, the maximum is 10. So here I
have 12.
If I fix that and run it again
so that's fixed, but now I have another
problem. So this is what's called an incomplete
problem. That's why I wasn't showing it immediately.
So the other was in hard violation,
but now it's something that could have been
solved if I provided more information.
So the problem here is if you see
that seats is actually a required
attribute,
but it's not specified for the last item
here. Right? And, really, the problem was that
there was an extra dash. That's really what
what it was going on here. So if
I run it now,
it's fine. Right?
So similarly,
if I
so open, for example,
another schema here.
Let's open the
so let's open the
already
have that. Let's say I have these two
schemas. Right?
And,
so one is an older version of the
other.
So let me
let me, run this again.
So here here, you see the queue is
a little bit easier to read. So if
I now combine that with the, the later
scheme I had,
so what you see is the the old
schema basically sets the seats, you know, every
table seats at least four people and at
most 12.
Their newest newer schema, you know, they'd like
to have a little bit more space. So
it says, you know, it seats maximum 10,
minimum two.
So if I combine these schema, it takes
the intersection of that, and it's greater than
four, smaller than 10. Right? Like, you can
use this to also check backwards compatibility of
schema and all these kind of,
kind of things. So let me move to
to a next demo here.
So open these files again.
One
thing that makes CUE work very well,
and this was already a realization that twenty
years ago in sort of the the ancestor
formalism that CUE uses,
is that if you have a a schema
validation
oops.
So I have codes.
So, can I do two things at the
same time?
So if you if you have a,
so if you have a schema for something
that really also,
at the same time as a template, right,
that you can use to reduce boilerplate, really
these two things. If you have to write
formulas, and these two are the same things.
So,
so one common use case for for CUE
is that you say, okay. We start out
with this whole bunch of JSON or YAML,
whatever you have.
Right? And now we first wanna check if
it's actually correct.
So what you do is you start with
the schema to sort of that captures the
rules and sort of your understanding of what
all this code is.
And then you start to, to run this
against your your YAML and JSON and see
if it's actually, you know, is the way
you thought it was. And then very often,
find tons of errors. Right? The first time
I started applying this to my own JSON,
I found and and YAML, I found tons
of errors.
And then once you've eliminated all these errors,
you can use the same schema to then
say, like, well,
you know, now I actually want this to
be, you know, like, reducing boilerplates.
Right? So it basically
does two things at the same time. So
let's see what's going on here. So what
you see here is not Kubernetes. It's a
simplified form of it, so it actually,
you know, fits within within one window here.
So but, you know, it's similar. So what
we have is
I can say I have a map of
deployments,
keys by their name.
Right? I say the kind is always deployment.
Their name is always the same as the
key.
So replicas,
I have a small service. So, usually, I
only have one. Right? So that would be
the default, but it can be any integer.
So there must be an image, right, of
string, and I have a few selectors
where
I say, you know, can be more than
that, but at least the the the app
should always be
the same as the name.
And then env, I now hardwire to prod.
Could be, you know, one
of a choice of a few things. Right?
But for now, I hardwire it. So same
thing. We have a a service doing something
very similar.
And then here, this is an interesting one.
So in this setup,
let's assume that for every deployment, we have
a single service.
Right? And so what I'm basically saying here
is that for every
deployment
and the way this this comprehension works
is that this is like a yield. Right?
Like, the final curly brace is a yield,
and that just gets dumped in, at the
configuration at that point. So, basically, what I'm
saying is here is that for every deployment
that we have,
there exists a service with the same name,
which has the same selectors and then, you
know, like, has a port,
the same as the port that's defined in
the deployment. We don't require this port here,
but it's this this implicitly assumes it's there.
So,
well, so the first thing we can do
now is we can say, well, let's see
if this even works. Right? So, actually, because
I use,
a package here at the top, I don't
have to, mention the files anymore, so let's
let's not do that. So the package basically
makes them combine altogether.
So let's run that,
and it gives two errors here.
And it basically says a trim line eight
column 12, which is here.
It says I I'm finding one,
right, you just type string, which doesn't match
integer. So I'm getting two errors.
So if you look at the schema at
the respective,
places,
the problem here is that,
you know, replicas is an is an integer,
but it has two values. Right? Like, integer,
the type, and the concrete value.
Could be simplified, I guess, by recognizing
you know, focusing on the integer part first.
But, you know, it found the error,
so let's fix that error
and then see if we're good now.
And, yes, we're good. So this is very
typical. Right? Like, you might think you have,
no errors in your configuration,
but that's you'll be surprised.
So now I I said, like, okay. Now
I wanna use this as a template. Right?
So how do that? How do you do
that? Like, well, first of all,
you
know, I can do an export on both,
right, as I did before, and you basically
see
I'm getting this full,
configuration.
So you see the ports are there. So,
you know, it's exactly as I was expecting
here.
So now but I now I know that
I can remove a lot of these fields
here. Right? So I see kinds,
all these things. I wanna basically remove those
and,
get the same results. Well,
if I wanna remove them, that's just simple
logic. Right? So why would you do that
by hand? So there's this command for it
called q trim.
So I'll run that now.
And then what you see, it has removed
here all the all the fields,
of my configuration that can be inferred
from my validation templates.
Right?
And then if I run q export again,
I'm getting the same results. Right? Because, essentially,
it only removes the things that could be
derived from this template.
So,
I'll have another little demo of where CUE
is heading, in the future,
but for now, I'll hand it back over
to David.
Thank you.
That was awesome. I have not
played with trim,
but that's a a very cool tool there
as well. And just a a nice good
overview of some of the the basics basics
of CUE.
So we did get a couple of questions.
So I'll try and throw them at you
now, and then we'll dive into the the
kind of live component as well. So Kevin
asks,
still not entirely clear on the trade off
between CUE and OPA.
Could we maybe discuss that a little bit?
I don't know. There's just a follow-up there.
This is actually probably it's CUE versus Regal.
What are the differences? Yep. Yep. That's a
very good question.
So so, basically, OPA is
or I don't know how you pronounce these.
The OPA or is it OPA? According to
the docs, it's OPA. Yeah. OPA. So that
means grandfather in in Dutch, just so you
know. So
anyway, so so
yeah. So OPA is more of a of
a product, right, whereas CUE is more of
a technology. So there is no equivalent of
OPA for CUE per se.
Right? What you could do is instead of
using Rego, right, like, basically, rig OPA to
use CUE instead of Rego.
Right? And and and and that would work.
So
Rego is more mature. Right? It's a further
developed language.
So so there are certain we did a
lot of recently, a lot of research in
in CUE into using it for policy in
in several contexts, actually. And there's a few,
you know, tiny features that are missing to
make it really powerful for for
for validation and and policy,
checking.
So you can expect more than for normal
data templating. You can expect more, rough edges
with CUE using it. Right?
On the other hand,
so if you see where CUE is coming
from, right, the the class of languages where
CUE is coming up from versus RIGO,
so there was this this well, I wouldn't
call it battle, but, you know, it's the
same people that wrote a prologue, basically, that
that went to develop sort of the successor
to it that that that fed into CUE.
Right? But Regal is basically based on Datalog,
which looks very much like Prologue. Right?
But when it came to configuration,
it it turned out that that Prologue really
didn't scale, and this is not from a
performance perspective. It's just, hard to understand.
Right? It was hard to combine,
the schema. So so, basically,
in the end, from for large scale engineering,
management, right, like, it didn't really work
for configuration.
Right? And then they came up with this
graph unification formalism,
which was very successful instead.
Right?
And so so CUE is basically the same
thing. Right? We I I believe it's it's
much better suited for configuration than RIGO.
It's actually designed so what you wanna do
in OPA is basically define constraints.
Right? So CUE is optimized for just the
constraint definition, whereas,
RIGO is, in essence, a query language.
Right? But, but definitely,
you know, Rigo is is is more ahead.
So so it's sort of like how
much,
you know, do you wanna get into the
early bandwagon. I mean, we definitely
you know, we're definitely making it a fully
fledged
policy
language.
Right? So another thing you can see is
if you unify all these different domains together.
So with Rigo, you really only can specify
policy. Right? Like, you wouldn't wanna define data
or templating in in in Rigo. Right?
So so with CUE, you get a solution
that covers the entire spectrum. You have to
learn less.
But the other nice thing about it is
because it functions at all levels, you also
can go meta on it. Right? So it's
you can define schema for your validation. Right?
So you can define the space of what
are valid validations.
Right? And so the this is something you
can make it arbitrary
meta,
basically.
Yeah. I I I think you've answered that
great. I'll just reiterate the bit that I
think is really important is that Regal really
just does
constraints
Yeah. Validate you know, validation constraints. Does this
document match my constraints? Whereas Yeah. He does
much. I I love Prolog. Don't get me
wrong. Right? But it's this is just purely
practical engineering. Yeah.
So so I wanna I see that Bart
has a question.
Or Yeah. I'm gonna put that up right
now. So
yeah. Bart Lomey has asked. Thank you for
the explanation. As we learned, CUE is read
but when you configure something, you're writing configuration.
So there's lots of edit and write processes
involved.
Exactly. Yeah. So so so
yeah. So definitely,
we wanted to make it read friendly
even if that meant sometimes making it less
write friendly.
Right? And what we hear from SRE so
far, which is almost the polar opposite of
GCL. Right? Like, GCL is very easy to
get going. So that would be sort of
a a, you know, JSON equivalent. It's very
easy to get going and and be very
you know, generating stuff quickly,
but it very quickly becomes complicated. Right? Like,
you cannot see where values are coming from.
Whereas in CUE, it's sort of the opposite.
Right? Because you have these these restrictions also
might for very well be because you're not
used to not having this inheritance and being
able to override.
Right? So because you have these restrictions, it
put a lot of restrictions on how you
can can organize things, which might be very
hard in the beginning. Right? So writing it
is indeed,
potentially more complicated than than with, JSON or
GCL or whatever. So we do think, it's
a matter of getting used to. Right? But,
even I have to get used to it,
at times. Right? It's a but on the
other hand, it you know, we we had
this bug in CUE a while back, and
somebody gave us these
hundreds of files of CUE. Right? Like like,
thousands
many thousands of lines generating. It was not
that big, but generating a hundred thousand, hundred
20 thousand lines of of
JSON,
basically.
But, you know, it was still complicated enough.
And
to prove whether it was a CUE bug
or a bug in the configuration took about
one minute. Right? We basically could very quickly
narrow it down. You could find the two
relevant lines in the in the queue,
and you knew that they were just dumping
all files together. Right? So we just from
these two lines, we just knew what the
answer had to be. Right? Like, there's no
inheritance change to follow. Nothing. Right? Like, it
was literally one minute to figure that out.
Right? So
that's that's,
yeah, that's something you just just can't forget
with with GCL, basically.
Awesome.
Alright. We've got one more question, and then
we'll get the my screen shared for some
live stuff. So Kevin is asking,
would or could I use CUE to start
a code gen pipe thing? For example,
CUE based service definition to generate gRPC code.
Yeah. So at the moment,
all the at at least within the CUE
framework, all the generation
is
custom implemented. Right? So gen you can generate
open API, for example,
which is part of the way there. But
for anything custom,
it's it's
a a little bit tricky.
So there are some third party,
you know, Accenture usage of CUE where, basically,
they use the the Go templating engine. So
there's a Go templating
engine built in, right, to to generate all
kinds of stuff. Right? So
I'm less familiar with that, to be honest.
So it's
but, you know, there's definitely other people that
have been working on that. So one of
the ideas is that at some point, we
also have a sort of custom
generation
packages that you can use to make this
generation more easy more easily, right, or make
it more easy.
But for now, this is all hardcoded.
But as I said, there are third party
solutions
for that that I haven't
digged in too deeply, to be honest.
There is the ability to generate
protobufs, isn't there, I think?
Or is that a fact of our buff?
More the so for protobuf right now, it's
the other way around. Alright. Okay. So we
we can take proto definitions and turn it
into CUE.
0.4
alpha also generates,
proto values. Right? But that's that's something else.
But, yeah, generating
gRPC
is is
very well possible. So the only thing it
doesn't do yet,
so so design suggestions are absolutely welcome, is,
so the service service definitions.
Right? Like, that's not really done natively in
in CUE yet. I mean, of course, you
can model it in data, but you wanna
have some native representation
for that in in CUE.
There's some proposals for that, but narrowing
it down to what people want would be
be nice.
Cool. We have one comment. That's not a
question, but I'll I'll pop it up anyway.
Anna says, their docs were previously generated by
CUE and it worked great. Awesome. Despite your
initial suspicion, no suspicion. Come on, Anna.
But the total owner just seemed young. Yeah.
I guess that's fair. CUE CUE is young,
but it's evolving quickly and,
you know, it's it's doing great things. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. Alright.
Let's get my screen shared.
This is the CUE homepage. So if anyone
wants to, you know, dabble along and play
with the tutorials themselves, you can find them
at qlang.org.
We will pop over to the documentation.
And I guess we could take a look
at a few things. So we cover some
of the the language basics from here, and
then maybe just try and go a little
bit deeper before we finish on your slightly
more advanced demonstration.
Yep. Okay.
Alright. Let's just pop into the tutorial. So
I'll just try and trim this. Hey, that's
a nice pun for today. I'll trim this
based on what you've already kind of shown
as well. So I don't think we need
to pop into the introduction.
And I think it probably covered most of
the types
and your
your starter demo. So
I guess this may be worth mentioning on
top and bottom. These are things that I
get I think I tripped up on at
the start of my my CUE journey. Do
you wanna give us a little bit of
introduction to those?
Like Yeah. So so
so the way CUE handles it, that it
always can combine something, is it defines this
this value
lattice,
if you will,
which basically means that any two values you
take, whether it's just a integer or an
entire configuration, if you combine them, there's always
a single unique,
answer to this to that. And,
you know, this is kind of mathematically, you
don't really have to to know about it
too much, but then,
you know, like, the the the value that
everything combines into ultimately is called bottom.
And, really, this shouldn't have been put in
the language, right, like this this sort of
offensive symbol there.
Really, we should have just called it error,
make it a build in where you can
pass a message as well. Right? And this
is still something we wanna do,
which is which is which is easier. Yeah.
Is there a specific thing you were tripping
over or or this weird symbol?
Yeah. I think it was probably just more
the symbols, you know, especially as I started,
you know, maybe really great in CUE documents
and you'd see something, you know, like this
or
I don't know. To me, it just didn't
it wasn't intuitive.
Yeah.
Oh, no. That's not it. Yeah.
I can't even remember. Yeah. But
I think it just it confused me at
first. It just took a
little bit of understanding and that when I
give something to CUE that it that it
is trying to turn it into a concrete
value. And then when I started to understand
that that was happening and then validating it,
I guess, by doing that, think things started
to get a little bit easier.
Yeah. Hello. I'm
I'm still very much learning CUE.
Every day I learn something new, which is
great. We
all do. Yeah.
Alright. So numbers and strings, those are all
covered.
We talked about,
you know, you mentioned concrete values and closed
values and stuff. Should we cover just a
little bit about this? Maybe we should create
like a little document with a schema to
actually explain these values. Yeah. So let me
do a main dot queue.
Okay. So you've already shown off like,
we can do something like this, which has
a default value. The default values are
star based. So I could do
this. Right? This is
valid queue document. Let me get a terminal.
You you don't need the outer curly braces,
by the way? Just to say. I think
that's just a nasty habit. I've I've actually
Yeah. Well, it's not necessarily nasty.
Yeah. I don't know why I do that.
I think we're I don't know.
So we can do an eval on main
dot queue, and then we see that the
name is coming out with David with that.
And I think one of the things that
I also struggled with when I'm first starting
with CUE, this is gonna just be my,
I think, my eating session of all the
things I learned the hard way, is that,
you know, you can
bring things in. I don't know why I
picked John. I really should have picked Marcel.
Is that I could bring oh, there we
go.
Is that we can bring in new values?
And this this whole concept of the constraints
living next to the actual data that I've
got just took a little for me to
become more accustomed to. Like, to understand that
these were unified to give something that I
could export
Took a little while for me.
Yeah. The the default thing is a bit
weird, but and the original formalism that I
worked with so so Michael asked, have I
ever wondered what this work with or exposed
to description logic? So not specifically many types
of logic, and the symbol definitely comes from
from logic,
absolutely.
But
yeah. So so so the
the form systems I originally worked with did
not have these defaults. But for, like, cloud
configuration
and many types of configuration,
you really do need this.
And this is CUE's CUE's way of cheating.
So, really, this is one level of of
of, this is basically a override. Right? So
this is an overlay, if you will. But
you basically only have
one level, plus it's very clearly marked that
this value might change. Right? So if you
see star David and string,
you know there might be another value that
overrides it. Or if you see Marcel, you
know that that's it. Right?
But, yeah, that is a bit
but this basically allows us to get away
with inheritance and still be able to reduce
a lot of boilerplate.
Yeah. And that one level of override just
means that that I can't then come back
in again and change this value because it's
it's already concrete. Is that the right terminology
at this stage?
Yep. Alright. Okay. Yeah. Have two conflicting values.
Yeah.
We had a comment from Paul, but I'm
not sure if this was maybe related to
the gRPC questions. I will just put it
on the screen anyway.
But Paul is suggesting
in get pretty far using template and using
cue string interpolation,
which has the added benefit over go text
template.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yep. Yeah. CUE has pretty nice multiline strings.
So this is taken from Swift, actually, which
is,
yeah, pretty powerful.
Is that these raw strings here?
Yeah. I didn't know I actually already had
a tutorial about it. It's like, yes. That's
it.
Yes. So we get the description
with the one to I've never used this.
This is a
long
string.
Now you need to close it with two
hashes also.
Yeah.
So you don't need the two hashes. The
two hashes basically escape the escape character. Right?
So you can you'd now need with two
hashes, you need backslash hash hash
to to escape.
Right. So I think the idea originally comes
from Rust and then Swift modified it.
Yeah.
I think Rust does have Rust looks little
bit different. Yeah. Exactly. It's
it's the same principle, though.
Okay. So we also were taking a look
just there at this concept of, like, a
closed struct and structures in general. So why
don't we just define like a simple structure
and then try and understand the dynamics of
what does it mean to be closed or
or not closed.
CUE uses the hash symbol or pound symbol,
whatever you call it,
to define structs
like this.
And then those can have any arbitrary properties
in it. Again, I could do something like
this.
Now,
what is special about a definition in CUE
versus like a normal struct?
Is there? It's
well, it's it's just really like any queue
value, but
we conflated a few of the concepts there,
which which generally is a very bad thing
to do. But in this case, I think
it was the right choice.
So if it starts with a hash,
that basically means so it's a definition that
basically means it's recursively closed.
But, really, if you define an API, it
really shouldn't be closed. Right? Like, you want
APIs to be extensible.
So,
basically,
the recursive closeness is just for the purpose
of error checking. So you can compare it
to proto buff. So if you, have a
proto definition, right, that you, convert to Go
and you have a unknown field, right, like,
you you you cannot basically access an unknown
field within this generated Go code. That's a
compile error.
And that's really how you should see structs
within CUE.
Right? Even though the proto, in theory, should
allow other fields as well, and it shouldn't
be an error if you have an incoming
message to get other fields,
you do wanna have that type checking within
your code. Right? And this is exactly what
a definition does. Right? So it's open in
principle but type checked.
It's it's signals queue to type checkers for
for, you know, like, in in a closed
setting.
That's really what this is. Does that make
sense?
Okay. Yes. Thank you.
I I think one of the things that
also tripped me up and
oh, no, that didn't do it. Oh, it's
export. Right?
Is it
yeah.
These kind of definitions don't come out the
other side as well as like there's a
concept of a private field as well,
something like this, which also
doesn't come out in the data. I think
I guess what I'm saying is my biggest
hurdle was just this these two things living
by the side by side. And it just
took a little while to get used to.
So I guess I'm just trying to make
that clear for the people that are watching
that, you know, these are things that can
trip you up, but they're very they work
pretty well when you understand that. Yeah. One
obvious thing that's missing from the documentation is
sort of an explanation of what all the
prefixes mean. Right? So there's underscore and hash.
So you also see dollar sign, which really
doesn't mean anything to CUE. It's it's just,
you know, JSON schema thing.
So but, basically, just a short description, like,
what what do these things mean and and,
like, why are they there and how should
you interpret it? Right? That would be very
helpful just at the very start.
Yeah. So and and your opinion then, like,
you know,
people have configuration,
you know, as a substrate for pretty much
all of our applications. We need to be
able to configure things regardless if we're deploying
to Kubernetes or we're deploying
using cloud formation or any of these Terraform
style syntaxes and stuff.
Like,
is CUE something that people should adopt
to define the constraints and validate those configurations?
Or is the eventual goal just to have
CUE being the actual
config layer too? Does that make sense?
Yes. Well, so so there's
multiple things to it. I think when it
comes to pure data specification,
I'm not sure if you would wanna send
CUE over the wire
per se. Right? Like, you wanted something, like,
really dumb and simple like like JSON.
Dumb and simple is good here. Right?
But for
yeah. And then and then also, a lot
of people don't need to specify more than
a few
lines of configuration. Right? And then they really
should do it in what they're whatever they're
comfortable with. But anything sort of on top
of that if you start
defining constraints or even, you know, as as
a specifying data to meet CUE is is
much nicer than than YAML, for example. Right?
Like, I have I have the auto formatting,
auto indent, which is kinda hard to do
in YAML. Right?
So so for me, it's it's it's much
nicer
to specify data in it, but it's that
shouldn't be a requirement,
right, to to do.
But, yeah, policy
validation,
all that stuff. Yeah.
Okay. I guess we'll we'll cover a few
more basic things, and then we'll maybe we'll
work our way through the Kubernetes tutorial. Tutorial.
So once we have definitions like this, we
can begin to to use these definitions
like so.
And that's the finds key constructs, which can
have a list of any number of definitions
of structs. And I'm already hitting myself for
the per naming on this, but
we can now say that this is a
list which has an object.
Hopefully I'm not gonna mess this up,
which has age. And I'm gonna get this
wrong on purpose just like you did in
your demo.
Zero.
So
I should, I believe,
be able to run an eval on this
and we should see an error saying that
the first value, enter a list of structs
is invalid because the age is the wrong
type to find in the definition here.
That look okay?
Yep. We'll find out.
There we go. Cool.
And if I set that to 21,
we get our structure at the other end,
but we if I export that, we can
remove all of the private information and just
get the raw data.
Cool.
I didn't mess it up too badly.
Is there anything else you think is worth
covering from this list before you do the
Kubernetes one?
Maybe,
like, disjunctions or bounds.
Yes.
Okay. So shall we add a disjunctions? So
we say that
our really terribly named structure here could only
have
two values and because we are here,
we'll do
this.
This is what we call a disjunction. I
think of a calculator there kind of threw
me at first. Do wanna just talk about
that if you don't mind?
Talk about what? So disjunction, is is this
from the mathematical
concept of the the thing here, or does
that come from somewhere else?
Yeah. It's it's basically
being able to say something can be an
integer or a string or one of two
values. And because q
it's it's a little bit hard to name
this construct, right, because CUE unifies types and
values.
So if if it were defined on values,
you would call it an enum.
Right? And if you if you if it's
a, you know, a programming
language type, you would call this a sum
type.
Right? So it really depends on what you
use it for. Also, you can use it
for if you're looking up in a map
and you you you want that to succeed,
you can say this is the default value
or or, you know, this is the
if everything goes well, I wanna take the
map lookup. But if it fails, I wanna
take a default value.
So that's like no coalescing.
You can do that too. Right? So,
So really because it unifies
everything, it's this one operation for for many
purposes,
which makes it hard to name. Right? But
disjunction is a very generic
name for these kind of things. Yeah. It
because I think all of the challenges I
had with CUE was pretty much they're all
my fault. It's that I probably didn't spend
enough time going through the documentation, looking at
the vocabulary,
understanding the syntax.
You know? I I pretty much just started
writing CUE and using eval and export export
loops manually, like like print lane debugging, I
guess, in a weird way. And it's not
until I see the error, you know, if
weekly set this to David two and run
that eval.
I was just oh, yeah. It's not until
I seen them that, you know, the word
disjunction here as, oh, And it just you
know, if you've not used that language before,
I guess it it threw me a little
bit. But, again, my own fault for not
spending enough time in the documentation. Yeah. It's
what I would do. I mean, with the
terminology,
You know, maybe these RMS just could be
made more earthly, but yeah.
Yeah.
So we can we can fix that, and
now we're we're back to have them working.
So this this pipe symbols, the ability to
specify that it can be one of multiple
types, one of multiple values,
it's a it's a junction. Cool.
And you also mentioned bounds. Is that just
like Yeah. Minimax It's simpler simpler thing, but
it's
it's an interesting concept, right, that you can
say
so you can compare you you have comparators,
right, like in any other language. You can
say,
you know, a is greater than b.
And then if there are two different kinds
of numbers, it sort of, you know, converts
it to the the common denominator.
So that's allowed.
Normally, it's pretty strict with types, but with
comparators, it's it's a little bit more, permissive.
But then you have this concept where you
have this unary comparator.
Right? And then it's really
a little bit like a spreadsheet validation,
fields, right, where you can basically say, this
value needs to be greater than three,
and you just write greater than three. Right?
And then the end symbol is the the
counterpart of this junction.
So you can specify many validators. Right? So
you can say this must be greater than
three, and it must be an integer, and
it must be smaller than eight or less
than eight. So you can combine many different
validators there.
Yeah.
In fact, I'll use a a real example
because the it shocked
me and amazed me when I first did
this. But I I I'm sure it's so
trivial, but I was so happy at the
time. But I was working on a a
dev rel platform to track all of our
events that we were going to, and we
wanted to store it in YAML, but we
wanted to be able to validate it before
we tried to build, like, the static site
that came out the other end.
And one of the things we had was
this concept, like, of a start date,
which
I'm I'm just gonna make it an end
right now because I'll forget how to actually
bring in the date time package.
But see, it's just an end. And it's
one, two, three, etcetera. And we have an
end date. It's like one of the things
I wanted to be able to do is
always validate that the end date actually came
after the start date.
Yeah. I I was actually when I was
doing that in CUE here is when I
realized that it was actually possible to do
that. And I'm sure I'll mess up the
syntax here, but is it just that?
Yeah. Yeah. So using CUE, we actually have
the ability to reference other properties within,
I guess, document. I'm not sure if there's
another word I should use there. But Yeah.
We can make references to other values and
make sure that they're valid. So here we're
saying that the start date the end date
must be
after the start date, and we can verify
that.
So one thing that might trip users up,
so if you go back to that oh,
yeah. You can
yeah. So don't forget the end percent. Right?
Like, the end because otherwise, it's int is
greater or equal to start date, which is,
in theory a valid queue expression. So we
try to catch these problems,
right, because it can never be satisfied, right,
because int will never be concrete.
Right? But
yeah. So so just don't forget the the
ampersand. Right? Like, that's the
Yeah. So we have our conditions here. We
have it actually failing.
So I guess
there. There we go. So our invalid value
is zero out of bounds greater than or
equal to one.
Is that about to do? And and just,
you know, it's not been particularly challenging that
this kind of write this document. I feel
that it reads really easy and I think
that's really powerful for people as we're trying
to validate this enormous amount of configuration that
we have in all of our application.
Cool.
I hope that people are as excited by
CUE as I am. I don't know if
I'm just weird that way.
But it just, you know, takes all of
these parts of our application that were really
difficult or we had to write really cumbersome
tests far before and just
brings it across a very simple data plane
or config
substrate,
whatever.
Okay. So
we're at
03:00. We got around thirty minutes left.
How long do you need for your last
demonstration?
Roughly.
The five
minutes. Sorry. Okay. Cool.
So let's try and use this now. I
think we've we've shown off just, you know,
queue constraints,
junctions, disjunctions, etcetera.
So we'll take a look at this Kubernetes
tutorial here. So
the goal of this tutorial is to show
people how they can
simplify
the Kubernetes manifest. Would you say that's
correct? Yeah. Everything, really. So convert, import,
manage,
validate,
simplify,
yeah, templatize.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I'm gonna skim this and I'm sure
I'm gonna miss bits. But let's see. So
what do I need to get started here?
I guess I need to run the CUE
mod in it.
Yeah. So you have to yeah. Well, yeah.
You can just start in this original directory.
Right? You don't necessarily have to copy it.
But
queue mod in it. Yeah.
Okay. Do I need the example.com?
I'm just trying to You don't need to.
No. That's yeah. It's not not mandatory. I'll
just create an e b c directory. Again,
my naming is always on point, but queue
mode in it.
Does this trying to so once you use
queue import to grab some YAML files and
convert them to CUE. So should I just
create a very simple Kubernetes
deployment?
Yeah. So basically, this this is based on
an existing dataset, right, that's being converted. So
you would have to copy that dataset.
Or do I need the whole thing, or
can I just create a deployment?
Does it matter? You you Yeah. It would
be easier to to copy the get the
Git repo.
Yeah. You're right. I shouldn't wing it.
Bad things happen when I do that.
Let's just clone it into here.
I'm sure there's a flag to tell it
to ignore that. I'll just do this.
K. So
what directory was that?
Doc tutorial.
So it's in yeah. You you go to
docs, yeah, tutorial Kubernetes.
Then original, you could do it there, I
guess,
if you don't mind modifying
the repo.
Okay. So queue mod and that from here.
Will that work okay?
Yep.
Because I feel like I've went off a
weird path now, but it should be alright.
Kubernetes original. Okay. So now we have our
queue module stuff here.
It's a simple we have this directory of
services,
and we want to then import
all of our services.
Like, so only that path is gonna be
different. Yeah.
I would go to
you in services already? Or yeah. You don't
have to, actually. It doesn't matter. That's
Okay. So you just want me to import
services like so?
No. Just c d into services. You don't
need to, but before
we forget later and, like, you know, command
to assume that you that you are. Yeah.
Yep.
We're importing all of this, so it's just
gonna be dot.
Is that right? All the all the subdirectories
too. So dot slash dot dot dot. Alright.
Okay. It's like that. Yeah.
Import everything.
Yes. So what this says, basically so if
you go back to the tutorial,
we'll do a little shortcut so you can
scroll a little bit down in the for
the sake of time. So I think,
yeah, if you take that command, I think
that should do it.
This one here?
Yep.
So, basically,
so all the Kubernetes definitions, they're all in
this flat space. So I like to have
these YAML files with the dash dash dash
in between. Mhmm. And what we're doing with
this import is that we're, putting it in
a namespace. So there's some feature features plan
to queue where you don't need to do
that. But right now, we're basically assigning them
each a unique name,
basically, by grouping them by
kind, right, like deployment or service and then
a name. And then,
so we're treating all of it in the
same namespace,
basically. And that's what this command does. So
it gives
it derives the name from the kinds and
the metadata name. And the and what the
dash r does, that's interesting.
So
some of these config maps,
so you can run this, for example.
Yeah. That should be fine. And then if
you look, if open the file in Mon,
the Mon in the Mon so there's a
subdirectory in services. There's Mon. Yeah.
And then Prometheus
and then config map YAML first.
So if you look there, there's this, you
know, sort of inconspicuous,
like like, pipe symbol, right, which really means
that what follows is not YAML.
It's a string.
Right? So that basically means, like, most of
the configuration in this file
is really treated as just one big string.
Right? Like, untyped, not even YAML structure. Right?
So the dash r option searches for these,
scenarios and then recursively converts that to queue
as well. So if you go to the
generated queue in config map dot queue,
you will see that,
you know, like, it also converted that
into into structured queue. And right now, it's
a let, but you can then manually assign
it to a field if you wish, and
maybe I'll make that an option so that
it does that automatically.
And then it has this
call to to YAML Marshall. And because it's
generated, it has these funky numbers to make
it unique. It has this call to the
YAML Marshall to to convert that back into
the original YAML string.
But, basically, it allows you to also recursively
validate the YAML within that queue. Right?
That's what that does.
Yeah. That's
almost magic. The fact that it's taken a
YAML multilane string and has kind of interrogated
it to see
if it is in fact itself more configuration
and then just giving you that back as
the
queue option. And this is one of the
problems in GCL, right, that it really had
only one layer of of validation, whereas very
often you have these nested configs and you
wanna be able to to
handle that as well. Right? Like, typing within
typing.
Well, I think you've made literally
everybody's head explode. So Julian Pavotto has said,
wow.
Kevin actually said his brain has exploded,
and Michael is agreeing. So there's
a lot of magic happiness, I think, in
the audience seeing that work. That was really
cool.
And now we've got
yeah. This is just cue representation
of that entire thing. Yep.
Yeah. That's very cool. So, basically, recursively imported
for all the directories, put it in that
directory.
So the directory structure of CUE, so they
all have the same package name.
We might
provide other modes. We're sort of looking into
what modes people wanna have, but the very
common pattern we saw is that,
you know, you have this directory hierarchy of
configuration
where, basically, you wanna have the the schema
and sort of the root config. It can
be a subdirectory too. Right? But there, specify
the schema that applies to all
the schema and the subdirectories. Right? So think
of it as ACL.
Right? So your validator that you specify there
sort of should apply to everything in the
subdirectory, very much like ACLs work or or
whatever. Right? And this is basically
how this is set up now. So now
you have this one package which crosses an
entire directory
structure.
And the CUE module basically is a single
hermetic view on all your configuration.
Right? So it's it's supposed to be completely
closed
and and fully defining everything what's going on
within these directories.
So that's that's the significance of that.
Cool. We had a a comment from Anna
who's suggesting that
CUE is a kind of data focused mix,
which is a quite an interesting way to
look at it. Are you familiar with NextLang
as well?
With Next, yeah, I am familiar with it.
Yeah. So
it's it's a nice language. Right? Pretty pretty
neat language.
So I think Next is more focused on
package management. Right? It's a more generic
the language itself is more generic, which you
can see it has some elements of it
where they are focusing on that.
It it so so a lot of the
more needs configuration languages like Dial and Mix,
they do focus more on functional,
whereas CUE really is more logic language. Right?
So I think ultimately for configuration,
because you have this aspect
orientedness, right, like, the you can really only
solve that with with logic
and and not so much with functional approaches.
So it's it's you know, depends on your
use case, but
yeah. So CUE takes quite a different approach
than DAO and and NICS, right, for that
for that reason. Not not to say that
there is
other use cases where it can be quite
useful.
Yeah. It looks like
Kevin and Anna are having a conversation about
potentially using CUE to validate next.
I can't keep up with it, but interesting
stuff.
Okay.
And there's a a nice joke from Kevin,
actually. Your recursive flag is to de ugly
things.
That's a way to look at it. Yeah.
Alright. So this is Let's see what this
tutorial is is doing next.
So we've imported
Yeah. So that all looks better.
Yeah. So that's
so create a top level template. Yeah. You
can
you can do that. I I would skip
the validation. It's not that interesting. You should
but yeah. So one thing that's interesting thing
to do, you scroll back up Oh, yeah.
Sure. So this is a very good pattern.
So I I showed you how to, given
a template, reduce configuration.
So theoretically,
so within graph unification is a known algorithm.
It's called anti unification. I could also do
the opposite. So given all the,
like, JSON and YAML we have now, like,
compute the optimal templates,
that after
running a trim would, would give the the
most compact configuration.
Right? Like, that's not,
implemented.
So but you can it it's actually quite
easy to do that by hand.
So what you would normally do is to
copy one of the templates that's sort of
representative,
for what you wanna do, right, or what
that you think this is sort of a
typical example of my my configuration. Copy that
to the roots,
right, and then start stripping anything specific to
it and and generalizing it. Right?
If you don't wanna do that by hand,
then you can do what this
cat,
know, block is doing. So this basically creates
an initial,
template, which is really a hand modified version
of one of the the the templates. Right?
So
we can do it by hands, but for
the sake of of saving time, you can
you can also just copy it. So that
you don't need to do. Okay. You can
either copy it and modify by hands, or
you can do the cat
thing, which already is the
sort of the modified version of that.
Okay. So let's grab
this
and just run this here. And this yeah.
In the root directory. So in services.
Don't know if you're in services. I was
in services. Yes. We've got a CUE.CUE now.
Yep.
And then so, basically, you see this short
example that I gave. This is pretty much
the same thing. Right? Like, you have
replicas.
You know? Like, there there's a few more
labels,
but it's basically the same thing.
Just scroll all the way to the bottom.
Oh, yeah. No. It's just these two things,
so I don't generate services from deployments.
But, yet, I don't do that here yet.
But, basically, I do the same thing. Right?
So I say, match any of the the
the names
in the service map. Right? And then I
basically say, okay. That name should be the
same as metadata name,
and that's, you know, all these little tricks
like that. Right? So there's a few few
of these. And yeah. That's the demo you
did at the start, right, where you created
a comprehension
over one of these and then just added
some extra constraints that locked the service and
the deployment together. Right. Okay. And the square
bracket basically means it's this this path selector.
Right? So the square brackets basically mean match
any path
of of you know, like, that I'm writing
here. And here, it's underscore, so it matches
any path in deployment. But you can also
say,
you know, anything that starts with a capital
letter or anything that that is
you know, ends with something or whatever. And
we're working now on an extension where you
can even say,
you know, like, matching patterns within the value.
Right? So you can really do very complicated
pattern matching there to to select where you
wanna apply this template.
Yep. Awesome.
Yep.
Alright. So what's coming up next in this
tutorial then?
This eval is
Yeah. You can run that
or that, whatever, and then you run into
errors.
So this is the idea here that if
you write down these validation rules, right, like,
very often
so so so you you might run into
errors in your configuration, but you also might
run into errors in the rules that you've
written.
Right? So
I haven't run this demo in a very
long time. So,
yeah, so one of it is that component
isn't defined
everywhere. So if you go back to the
tutorial.
So it mentions that. Yep. So, basically, component
isn't defined
everywhere, so especially in the
so so yeah. So so not all subdirectories,
you know, not all files and all subdirectories
have this defined. So here you see we
have a constraint. Right? Let's say we always
want this component label,
but it's actually not specified everywhere.
So if you run the code below, we
actually create a small cube file in every
directory
where we define this
this component label. Right? So that's that's some
shell wizardry that's not specifically CUE.
Yeah. I think I I I got kinda
confused when I copied this and just pasted
it, but now I actually see what we're
doing. We've we've created just, like, some constraints
to check all of our services and deployments.
Okay. And we're expecting them to have a
piece of metadata label that is component with
a value. Yeah. And and not everybody not
all of the files have that. So Okay.
So this is just suggesting that we use
set magic.
Yeah.
Know what happened there.
Oh, yeah. It's Oh, no. It's about it.
Yeah.
So it's created all these little files. Yep.
So, yeah, it's Prox?
There seem to be something wrong. There should
be proxy, but but either way. So it
might look run into more problems.
Is that just me failing at copying and
pasting? That's what it is. Right? Yeah. Don't
know what happened there.
I wonder if when I ran it here,
if I potentially broke something.
Oh, I think I definitely have.
I can always do it by hands but
See, the directory is called proxy, so I
don't know why that's
You can change the proxy.
It's probably a good idea.
Then I don't know if it got wrong.
And I'm not even getting the star.
Maybe it's a shell incompatibility.
Who knows? Oh, yeah. I'm running
that shell, which I guess should mostly work.
It's not important. I I think we can
have covered a lot of cool stuff there.
And I'm worried that my failure to copy
and paste has done something very weird there,
especially the one I control seed, which was
halfway through, like I said.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm not sure.
Alright. Awesome. I will
pop that away.
And we'll jump over to your last demo
and we'll we'll finish up. If
anyone has any questions,
feel free to jump them into the comment
section,
and we'll be finishing up in the next
five to ten minutes.
You looking for your window?
Or have you frozen?
Oh, no. You're there. I'm
here. So shall I start
Yeah. I think you said you had to
just pick a five minute Yeah. Thing. So
we'll finish with that, and then we'll we'll
do a quick recap, and we'll end it
there. Yeah. Yeah. The Kubernetes demo is is
quite long, actually, and it's it shows you
a lot of things of that can go
wrong. And and so the idea is that,
basically,
by the end of it, which is, like,
twenty minutes, if you run through the commands,
like, you see that you
reduced
the amount of configuration by half, roughly,
or maybe slightly more, slightly less. I I
I don't remember. But it's, you know, like,
this whole repetitive trim thing, like like, really
reduces.
And you can see we start with about
1,800 lines, and by the end, it's it's
like considerably less.
And that's just stripping down the boilerplate and,
you know, making things reusable
whenever possible.
Just it cleans things up a lot, definitely.
Okay.
Julian says he has a a thousand questions.
Well, we'll maybe try and answer a couple
of them. Feel free to drop them. So
so so I'll I'll give this this one
demo
first.
So
yep. It's a clean thing. So let me
just run.
So what I'm doing here so so this
is basically to to show that, really, there's
a logic engine behind it.
And and there you know, like, it really
doesn't you can use CUE for things that
have otherwise nothing to do with CUE.
So here I have a piece of Go
code, which has,
types
and validation code.
And what I wanna do now is to,
generate open API from this. Right?
So,
basically, the first thing I have the commands
handy. So so,
course, nothing. Okay. Fine. I should do it
by hand.
Gets go
local.
Do I have to yeah. Current directory, I
guess. Let's see if that was the command.
I think so.
So if I run get go, what it
does, basically, it analyzes this Go code.
So this already works.
And then
generates
this restaurant
gen Go gen queue.
And what you see here is this nicely
documented,
you know, like like,
queue representation of the Go types in this
file. So this is nothing really too spectacular.
Right?
What you can see, though, is that I
also have this validation code
defined on table,
which has constraints. Right? And I would like
to have these constraints represented in queue as
well.
So
I love, you know, like, think tinkering with
SSA.
So
so what I wrote is this little SSA
analyzer.
What it basically, what it does is first
tries to identify
a validation code.
And the way it does that is is
if a code has no side effects and
returns an error, it consider its validation code.
And then I can see, of course, it's
like, well, this is a method on table
that validates or takes table as a first
argument either
way.
Right? So this must be something that validates
table.
And then, basically, what it runs what it
does, it runs over all possible paths in
the SSA,
you know, representation of that code
and tries
to find cases where it knows it will
return an error and then sort of logically
reasons backwards to get, to get facts, from
that. Right? So let's do that now.
And this has been, run also on the,
Istio code base for which I did some
analysis.
And I was able to, so so just
to give you an idea of the coverage,
I was able to get a % of
the validation code. Right? So the,
the the accuracy, both recall and precision, there
was a %. And about 95%
of all possible code paths,
I was able to determine whether it would
return an error or not. Right? Then the
rest sort of was,
the code sort of had to give up.
So if we look at what this produced
so this was, yes, s s a dot
q.
This produces something else, and it's, so this
is only one constraint. Right? So this is
quite simple. But if you if you have
many constraints, it becomes quite barfy. Right? Like,
you get all these weird because it's out
of a logical negation, it gets this dump
of of all kinds of facts.
And then, basically, if you wanna combine that
into a single table,
right, we now do CUE
DEF, which means schema. Right? I don't wanna
get to the concrete data. I wanna define
a schema.
So we can say CUE DEF,
SSA, and what what's the other one? Restaurants,
go.
Now you see we have the same schema
documented,
right, with the constraints,
inside now.
And then, of course, I can also do
out open API.
Now we have that same schema in open
API. So here you can see we have
a
open API,
you know, like, definition of the original,
GoCodes
without any further specification from the user. Right?
So that's what
that's what happened here. So this is kind
of the
thing you can do with this with this
CUE ecosystem. Right? It's the idea.
Damn.
So I just wanna make sure I understood
that right. That was just random not random,
but, you know, that was just go code
where using CUE get go, it was doing
static analysis of that code to work out
what the constraints were on it from the
different functions that interact with the data and
then generate in the queue constraints.
Yep.
You then merge the or unified, I guess,
would be the correct or unified the two
different queue files and then output it in
open API schema.
Document it. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. That's the, yeah,
that's the idea. This
is even though, you know, like, in my
analysis
so I I was able to extract these
facts
for 95% of the code paths. Right? Like,
that that doesn't mean,
it's already implemented. Right? Because now you have
to translate that to to something concrete.
And that's, that's doable, but you have, like,
you know, hundreds
or about a hundred or so, like, in
that order, like like, different cases you in
edge cases you have to handle. Right? So
it's kinda tedious to implement,
but it's definitely possible. And and, you know,
also, it didn't take too long. It runs,
like, within a minute, right, on the on
the Istio code, more like twenty seconds or
so. So it's it's it's quite excessive to
go for all possible code paths, but it's
it's definitely doable.
Yeah. There there's just so much magic there.
There. I think I'm actually gonna need time
to think that one through and understand it.
But the I mean, the applications of that
across a whole variety of different code bases
is a is a pretty cool thing. Very
exciting. Yep.
Alright.
Sorry. Question. I
think everyone is speechless. I don't think we
have any more questions.
There's not been anything since the the the
magic static analysis stuff.
So I think what we'll do is,
I mean, all of that was great. Thank
you so much for taking the time today
to to join me, you know, not just
introduce us to CUE, but show us some
stuff that's coming next and and even just
getting some of that experience out of your
head to understand the why as well. I
think it's just been completely invaluable.
So thank you very much. I'll let you
get back to the rest of your day.
If there are any more questions, people can
ask them in the YouTube comments. I'll do
my best to relay them on or join
the Discord, and we'll take it from there.
So, Marcel, thank you again. Have a great
day. We'll speak to Thank you for having
me. My pleasure. Yeah. If anybody has questions,
feel free to contact me.
GitHub discussions,
there's you can ask questions there. That's our
main portal for asking questions now. So Yep.
There are links to all of this and
the description the video to the CUE repository
to Marcel's Twitter, and I think there's even
a link to the CUE community Slack channel
as well. So lots of way for people
to get involved, get in touch. Again,
thank you. Have a good day. I'll speak
to you soon. Well, thanks.